good morning John I'd like to introduce
you to a couple of my friends there's
four down here that's Kaylee Leanne
Lauren and Kristina and they all like to
hang out together cuz they're awesome
and that's Haley she couldn't come
then there's rosianna who's pretty small
there's the short sistered over here who
are a tiny they're all my terminus
friends hi guys
terminus is fun isn't it let's go oh god
that one just moves so that was uh okay
that turned out to be a worse punishment
than I expected someone suggested that
and since most people who commute of
punishment at all I decided that I would
just do that since someone suggested it
and it seemed easy and peculiar but then
one of them was still alive died already
oh that's what you call the willies I
have them seriously my heart is beating
really hard right now
for my legs and both of my fangs are
still perfectly active here I come Oh
instead of sprayed it with Windex
beforehand or something oh god there's
spiders in my face but for those of you
who are upset about that I'm killing
spiders I wouldn't do it if they weren't
the kind that eat you in the near leg
rot sauce I have to work down here but I
don't want leg rot there's I can see one
on the wall right there hold on I'm
gonna go kill it Mental Floss d-done
basically as you know if you watch my
last video I had at least eight days of
pure awesome in a row that actually
turned out to be about 10 days of
awesome thanks to John's peanut butter
face in Georgia discussion and also my
wife being fantastic and being very glad
that I was home and having a sort of
metric Sabbath on the tenth day he
rested and it was awesome and that was
like day 12 and I am sort of coming down
coming down on the way down I spent a
lot of time thinking and writing about
terminus and but all the stuff that went
on in New York City and now I'm home you
know and just doing my thing and it's
taking me a little bit of time to get
kind of back into normal swing of things
and there's been a component of me
that's sort of crashing and it's all
like
I'm mr. Zhu
I spot some girls and shiny beans and
wizard rocky nerd party no I mr.
Minister why mr. minister
and maybe a little pathetic oh just a
little a little tiny candy pathetic very
small amount of patheticness but it is
there Esther Oh pathetic but that's part
of life every week can't be the
awesomest week ever and the Kathryn and
I are actually about to reinstate the
awesome we're gonna go to Yellowstone
next week and check out Yellowstone so
hopefully we'll have some yellows do a
foot egde to show you all and then we're
going to be with this thing that joined
it together and holy matrimony two more
of my very good friends because
apparently that's the kind of summer it
is unrelated Leigh while I was at
terminus lots of third fighters that's
about the nerdfighter t-shirt contest
that is in the works and hopefully you
will see a video of it soon Oh what's
wrong with me
today I ate pathetic I played the
spiders I'm having hand things I should
probably just go this being a very
strange and hopefully somewhat
entertaining video but I don't want to
go on too long because is weird so I'm
just going to Lou Jon I'll see you soon